my spider-sense is tingling so I saw
Avengers infinity war the other day
pretty much as soon as it was available
that night and as expected it was
awesome in fact it was even better than
I expected it to be as usual I'm now
inspired by having watched that and I
want to make a video on it in this video
I'm gonna be looking at how you can
develop reactions just like spider-man
in other words can you develop a real
spider sense so first off let's start
with the bad news there is no such thing
as a spider sense however what we do
have is the ability to detect a danger
that were unconscious of that we're not
aware of so in a recent study scientists
researchers showed participants faces
that they'd been taught to fear in one
eye whilst distracting them in the other
eye so they wouldn't be consciously
aware of those faces and what they found
was that although the participants
weren't aware of those scary faces they
still showed a physiological response
sweat on their fingertips and elevated
heart rate all that good stuff so even
though they didn't know those faces were
there they knew they were in danger and
this is something that we all do to an
extent of course there are
methodological problems with that study
for instance how can you be completely
sure that they didn't just see the face
but on the other hand it does lend
support for something we already know to
be true and this is that you can
register things in your periphery and
respond to them even before you're
consciously aware of them so we've taken
a huge amount of data from a lot of
sensors far more information than we can
attend to at any given point and thus
our brain has to filter that information
and tell us what to focus on normally
this means focusing on what's directly
in front of us what we're doing but
we're still aware of the stuff in the
peripheral are still aware of those
background noises of the temperature
changes etc and if something dangerous
should be detected here then suddenly
our attention will switch will switch
focus to that thing so that we can
escape this is why our ears pick up when
we hear someone say our name in a
crowded room is to call the cocktail
effect and it's also why we get that
sensation that we're being watched and
then we look up and we are it's not
because we have some kind of sixth sense
we cool it's because we have gaze
perception and that allows us to quickly
work out where someone's looking so if
from the corner of your eye and you're
not even aware of it you can detect
where someone's looking and they're
looking at you then your brain will say
hey I'm in trouble or this person wants
to speak to me and your attention will
switch to that person we actually have
specific brain networks specifically for
gaze perception this is an important
aspect of our psychology so we have the
ability to react to stuff before even
aware of it and that's the closest we're
gonna get to a spider sense what we need
to do is make sure that we can detect
that stuff and better and respond to it
react to it too quicker and there's a
few ways we can do this the first is to
make sure that we focus on enhancing our
senses I've talked about this several
times in the past I've done a video and
a post on daredevil training to check
that out but I'm gonna focus for the
moment on peripheral vision because
peripheral vision is something I've also
touched on a bit and it's just generally
super cool and important so our eyes are
filled with photoreceptors which detect
light and then relay that information to
the brain where it's assembled and
turned into something that can actually
understand we have far more a far denser
cluster of photoreceptors in the center
of the IV focal point the phobia that we
do around the periphery however those
peripheral photoreceptors are actually
much quicker sending signals to the
brain 25% quicker in fact so if you see
something in the periphery of your
vision you can actually respond to that
react to that far quicker than you can
if you're looking directly at it which
is strange but it does explain why when
you open a cupboard and all the stuff
falls out you're able to really quickly
catch it even though you'd normally
don't have those sort of lightning
reflexes again this is getting into
spider-man type territory the good news
is that thanks to something called a
visual plasticity which is very similar
to brain plasticity which others just
did a whole video on it is possible to
create new photoreceptors or restore or
improve existing ones
through training so by training your
peripheral vision you could detect
information from the corners of your
eyes quicker and respond to that
information quicker as well once again
this is said specific adaptations to
oppose demands meaning that the best way
to improve our peripheral vision is just
to practice using it and there are
programs out there computer programs
that will allow you to do this they
normally involve focusing on ace
to a point a pixel while something
happens on the edge of the screen then
you have to say as soon as you see that
thing another exercise you can use is
something called the straw and
chopsticks so you hold a straw in the
center of your vision and you draw a
line down the middle where you get
someone else to hold it we can prop it
up on a table then you're going to use
chopsticks and here the hand and whilst
staring right at the center of the straw
you're going to try and feed the
chopsticks into the edges of the straw
and as you get better at that you can
make the straw longer by attaching
multiple together another cool way to
train your peripheral vision and your
reflexes is juggling which also
encourages a lot of hand-eye
coordination and ambidexterity likewise
bouncing a ball against the wall and
especially if you keep your vision on a
fixed point in the center and then try
and react to that fall again using both
hands even better and that way you're
using a peripheral vision and you're
trying to quickly react to things that
happening before you can potentially
even think them through I've talked in
the past about something called
wide-angle vision or our lies or
splatter vision to activate this you
simply engage your peripheral vision and
a trick for doing it when you're
starting out is to put around that by
your side like that with all your
fingers and then focus on the fingers
wiggling out the corners of your eyes
while still looking forward to now
you've activated that kind of wide
spread of vision this will allow you to
respond to things quicker to take in
more information and also actually
lowers your heart rate and makes it
easier to enter a flow state or
meditative state it does this because
there's a two-way correlation between
focusing and physiological arousal in
other words when our heart rates up we
tend to focus more on what we think is
dangerous and when we calm our eyes
spread out so this is a good way to calm
yourself down also and in fact is a form
of Hawaiian meditation called hack allow
or hakalo I don't Haven outs it this is
all about engaging your peripheral
vision they say to do it simply by
sitting down somewhere quiet focusing on
a point on the wall and then letting
your vision spread out to the sides and
when you try it you'll find it is much
easier to empty your mind and into a
state of calm this should also mean
you're now more ready to react to sounds
or movement or anything else you need to
quickly respond to similarly during a
fight good advice is to try resting your
gaze on the chest of the opponent they
focus on the center of the chest don't
look for Telegraph to movements just
allow your eyes to rest on that general
area then trust in your peripheral
vision and your reflexes to react to
their movements and to know where
they're looking thanks to your gaze
perception etc so now we have an
improved ability to detect danger the
next thing to do to try and improve our
reaction time so it can respond more
quickly when it happens or we can back
flip over doc Ock's tentacles as they
come hurtling towards us have you ever
wondered why cats have such great
reflexes where the term cat-like
reflexes comes from it might have to do
with greater myelination of the neurons
responsible for visual information in
other words the axons the tales of their
neurons have better insulation allowing
nerve impulses action potentials to
travel more quickly from the optic nerve
into the brain and to the processing
areas we can also increase myelination
throughout our brain to potentially
improve our reflexes and you can do this
through your diet by getting more
omega-3 fatty acids by getting more
sleep by getting more exercise and at
the same time by using a whole host of
different supplements and herbal
extracts and things several rat studies
of Shame needs to be effective and they
include gato Cola uridine ashwagandha
forskolin and lion's mane mushroom also
weather an interesting article recently
about the benefit of pre-planning what
you want to do in a potential dangerous
situation in other words if you drop
something what do you do do you kick it
do you grab it for instance we drop a
knife visualizing yourself and not
catching it but stepping out the way
could help you to react correctly by
essentially practicing those in your
pathways so you don't have to stop and
think about what you gonna do or
potentially grab it and catch it and
hurt yourself it's a common reflex for a
lot of people if they drop something to
kick it or to catch it on their foot so
it doesn't damage itself and it falls on
the ground I remember one time when I
was younger my mom asked me to carry
some coal saw into the kitchen shed our
guests around our neighbor and I picked
it up because I'm a dutiful son took it
to the kitchen dropped it and out of
reflex went to catch on my foot well I
actually ended up doing was drop kicking
it
and exploded everywhere and coleslaw
went all over my mom and all over our
elderly neighbor and all over the table
and I was in a lot of trouble once I
explained what I did they thought it was
very funny but yeah that was a bad
reflex so practicing your reflexes is
also important this is why martial arts
are so effective because you're
repeatedly reinforcing those neural
connections causing more myelination
causing more long-term potentiation like
Bruce Lee says it's better to practice
one kick a thousand times and a thousand
kicks once you can also just train to
increase your reaction speeds though
unfortunately this is largely genetic
and there's only so much roughly 10%
that you can affect this by so a good
reaction speed is 0.1 of a second and a
slow reaction speed is 0.4 most of us
will be somewhere between point 2 and
point 3 there are plenty of computer
games online and other things you can
use to test and hone your reflexes and
your reaction times one thing that does
increase reaction times of course is
stimulants using things like caffeine
there's lots of nootropics that will do
this but winding yourself up like that
isn't necessarily good improvement
something that we do know can increase
reaction times at least in an activity
specific manner is over speech training
I've talked about / speed training in
the past in the context of running but
actually performing any task more
quickly can help you to become better at
performing it slowly so for example some
Formula One drivers will drive in
simulations that go much faster than the
real cars so that they get better at
responding quickly and then when they
return to you know real-life speeds it
seems relatively slow it's possibly got
something to do with potentiation or
excitation of new neurons I'm not sure
how it works but it's the similar
phenomenon that we noticed when we come
off the motorway onto the side roads and
suddenly we feel like 30 miles an hour
is a crawl so over speed training could
be useful for training your reaction
times in a whole host of different
contexts on a side note maybe practicing
speaking more quickly could increase
your verbal fluency we know likewise
that plagued computer games can increase
your reaction times and why not try
turning up the speed on that if you spa
try sparring faster another cool method
of training reaction time in particular
could be trail running when you trail
run you're running through the woods
you're running through fields any kind
of rough terrain and you're trying not
to twist your ankle in a ditch try not
to trip over twigs or slip on the muds
this means you're using all of your
senses together not only your vision but
also your proprioceptive abilities your
balance in order to stay upright whilst
moving quickly you can also practice
your allies your wide-angle vision here
and this is generally going to help to
improve your reaction times and your
agility your lightness on your feet
which is all very spider money so yeah
those are some ways that you can
increase your alertness your awareness
but also your reaction times in order to
respond as though you had a real-life
spider sense it's the closest we can get
or is it there's actually two more
methods you could use to get a spider
sense both of which a bit more out there
and a bit more science fiction the first
of these is to use synesthesia there is
actually a real-life person with
something similar to a spider sense
called Barrett Bogart
they have synesthesia synesthesia being
a cognition that causes your senses to
merge the most common example being
seeing colors when hear music in the
case of Barrett brogard she would see
this kind of scene of scary mountains
and hills and they get this general
sense of dread as soon as she detected
danger even unconsciously so the story
that she recounts is walking through the
woods and coming closer stepping on a
snake she didn't see it but she caught
it in the periphery of her vision and
she would have stepped on it had it not
been for this sudden visual cue this is
called projective synesthesia I believe
she had the sudden visual cue in Jenin
not to step down on the snake and as
such it saved her life
this is the closest thing to real-life
spider sense we know that you can train
synesthesia studies have shown that it's
possible at least to some degree whether
or not you can train this specific form
of synesthesia I don't know but what
about for instance if you played some of
those games where you look out for
things in your peripheral vision or if
you played computer games and at the
same time try to visualize some kind of
cue to warn yourself on top of what
you're seeing I don't know if this can
work but if you practiced it maybe it
couldn't especially if you combined it
with techniques to increase your brain
plasticity
it's just an idea but it's definitely
cool
there's something out there and the
other option comes from something called
victim matter vit C and this is a guy
who's invented a suit that allows you to
experience what it might be like to have
a spider sense
it works by sending out signals I think
it's so neuro or something like that or
light infrared I'm not sure they bounce
back and when the suit detects that it
uses a haptic feedback so a small motor
or something like that and you feel it
through the jacket so this way you can
detect things that close to you behind
you it's your side in front at the same
time it's bit like having parking
sensors built into your jacket but as a
result you can dodge things you can
avoid hazards and it has a lot of
potential applications for people with
you know visual impairment at the same
time though it's also been suggested
that it could be used for for military
personnel and also people working on
construction sites you need to dodge
falling debris avoid stepping off of
things so it could just give you more
body awareness it's a really interesting
idea and what's also interesting is how
your brain would react to this
essentially additional sense and who
knows what's even cooler is that one day
this technology might be shrunk down and
implanted into our skin and then we'll
have transhumans spider sense and this
really could give us the ability to
dodge a pumpkin grenade thrown from
behind us that we completely don't even
need to look at because dodging stuff
without looking at it is way cooler so
you go that's just some thoughts on how
you might develop a real-life spider
sense unfortunately we're not going to
have preternatural awareness and
reflexes but we can increase our senses
to the point where we can react to stuff
that we're not even yet consciously
aware of and in the future there's some
really interesting possibilities for how
we might develop something close this is
one of those slightly more realistic
superpowers let me know in the comments
down below what you think if I've missed
anything I am interested as well in
spider-man's senses being used for
predicting kind of general danger and
whether or not there's anything to look
into there I'm not sure let me know in
the comments down below what your
thoughts are
likewise I'd love to know what you think
of Avengers infinity war and as always
thanks a ton for watching stay tuned for
more like this I'll be going over
Captain America soon like I say whether
or not you can create a real-life Super
Soldier Serum going to be talking about
how to think like Tony Stark and I've
got
all the usual stuff on the way I've
already half recorded a video on tendon
strength on my workout regime on
cognitive behavioral therapy and working
online another one so if that'll sounds
good then stay tuned thanks a ton for
watching and bye for now